we've been cooking all day and the first
guests are starting to arrive time to
assemble a Dumbo Brioni
the biryani is finished with spicy
Indian meatballs called kofta coriander
and tried apricot amazing ask him for
the first time this morning is he happy
with it hello putting it I had your
apnic yeah joking equal is happy with it
good excellence at the beginning I felt
like a bit of a spare prick at a wedding
10 minutes into it he made me feel like
a chef thank you that's [ __ ]
delicious hey Wayne if it was living in
Britain the last 84 years will have a
completely different take on Indian food
you know that I I swear to God it's
delicious
yeah authentic and amazing
now you look nice
this may look unusual to us but MTS has
his own ideas about presentation I'm so
fired up by what I've learnt and cooked
with one of India's top chefs the dishes
names are familiar but the food is
totally new to me next please I've
noticed India as a country of food is
they're very choosy about what they eat
and this Brioni is disappearing fast
it's so popular we fought to save a
portion for the bride unbelievable what
a day I want to set up I knew it's gonna
be good but I didn't think it's gonna be
that good just food from the heart soul
and passion and historic and he's given
me a lot of inspiration because that was
amazing